let's just bring you some breaking news
now on the economy and new figures from
the office for National statistics
confirms that the UK avoided recession
in the final quarter of last year so
let's bring in our business
correspondent Paul Kelso and Paul this
is a revision of the latest growth
figures isn't it how much of a relief
will it be to the government that it
hasn't indicated that we have slipped
into a technical recession
well it will be a relief and just to
explain what's Happening Here the office
for National statistics issues its
growth figures on a its estimates of GDP
how much the economy is producing and
whether it's growing or Contracting on a
monthly basis and then it revises them
as another look at it checks its own
work the following month and the reason
we're all up looking at this this
morning is it's reviewing the figures
for December 2022 and the final quarter
of last year and essentially checking
was there a recession stuck in the
Christmas post because in the third
quarter of the year the economy
contracted in the final quarter in
ending in December it was flatlining 0.0
GDP growth so the UK avoided that
technical definition of a recession two
quarters consecutively consecutively of
contraction that didn't happen today we
hear the figures actually revised up
0.1 growth in the final quarter no cause
of Celebration but definitely a relief
from the chancellor who we'll hear from
later
okay Paul thanks very much indeed yes
we'll hear from Jeremy Hunt shortly and
we'll bring that to you as soon as we do
Paulo thank you